are you all right I'm all right but
you've nearly frightened the life out of
him who this bag we're hunting see so
it's done just because it's what's done
doesn't mean it's what should be done
you're right i hope to see you again
miss ragged servant girl is what you are
and that is what you will always be wake
up your aligners you're in a daze it's
that wonderful girl I can't stop
thinking about it you will be king soon
her prince is not free to follow his
heart you must marry for the good of the
kingdom what on earth have you been
doing dreaming that's who oh then wake
up no one in the kingdom will outshine
my daughters
it's you kid just says
mama the hofstra could be right the
spell will be broken and all the water
turn toward a hospital are you looking
for this must be quite a story to go
with it keep that girl out of sight and
you and your daughters we get whatever
you desire someone like that doesn't
just vanish I have to see her again
I will protect the prince from you
no matter what the comes of me